but we begin with an urgent new warning
for parents about a respiratory virus
that's hitting infants and young
children harder and earlier than usual
this year it's called RSV and it's
basically the common cold the symptom
include coughing wheezing running nose
and decreased appetite but it's caused a
lot more respiratory distress in babies
and young children because of their
airways being much smaller cases have
more than doubled in 25 States over the
last month and it's putting a big strain
on hospitals Omar via Franca takes us
aside some hospitals where doctors fear
they could soon be overwhelmed
yep it's draining RSV cases are filling
up the emergency room at Cook Children's
Hospital in Fort Worth Texas one of
those patients is 19 month old Nash his
mother Jerry Akers told us she brought
him back to the ER after his symptoms
got worse we were here on Monday and
sent home because it was man
and really we didn't see
but my instinct this morning was like I
need to go back Dr Daniel Guzman is
treating the toddler RSV symptoms are
similar to a cold but he says there are
more signs parents should look out for
well they're breathing harder they're
breathing faster they're head bobbing
they're kind of moving their head back
and forth and they're making a grunting
noise that's when we want to take some
more action Dr Guzman says at least one
third of the ER patients he sees every
day have RSV we don't see this surge
typically until December or January and
sometime into February this is going to
be a rough uh winter season Dr Guzman
says the unusual timing of this surge
may be related to the pandemic well our
immune system has kind of taken a
holiday but now that we're back in
schools we're not wearing masks now
we're being re-exposed and now we're
seeing the numbers increase at
Connecticut Children's Medical Center
they are running out of space as the
virus surges we're having patients in
Hall beds we're using our Orthopedic
room we're using other treatment rooms
as much as possible all hands on deck
for CBS mornings I'm Omar villafronto a
Fort Worth
nothing worse than a toddler crying and
they can't tell you what's wrong good
luck to them you